cette dette il ya un an le 4 août 2020
une double explosion dans le port de
beyrouth fait 214 morts
et si 1500 blessés selon le ministère de
la santé libanais
des dizaines de milliers de personnes se
retrouvent sans logement
[Musique]
la ville est dévastée
les dégâts considérables le monde entier
sous le choc
à l'origine de cette terrible
catastrophe de l'île 700 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium un agent hautement
explosif entassés dans un entrepôt sans
grande précaution
le soir même le premier ministre hassan
diab annonce l'ouverture d'une enquête
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui impose
que des comptes soient rendus
les responsables de cette catastrophe
devront rendre des comptes
c'est une promesse que nous faisons aux
martyrs et aux blessés
c'est un engagement national un
engagement qu'il ne tiendra pas hassan
diab démissionne quelques jours plus
tard la capitale beyrouth s'embrase la
population libanaise déjà durement
touchée par une crise économique
historique se lance dans une
contestation qui met à jour une profonde
crise politique
[Musique]
un an plus tard l' enquête sur les
responsabilités liées à la catastrophe
est au point mort personne n'a été
inculpé un juge d'instruction avait été
récusé
après avoir mis en examen l'ancien
premier ministre
hassan diab et trois de ses ministres en
février dernier
ce lundi amnesty international a
reproché aux autorités libanaises
d'entravé délibérément les
investigations dans la foulée militants
et proches des victimes ont lancé un
ultimatum au pouvoir en place pour lever
l'immunité des hauts responsables
inculpés
[Musique]
car pour les libanais ces accusations
sonne comme un nouveau coup dur alors
que la révolte commence à l'emporter sur
le deuil notre blessure grandi et
s'approfondit chaque jour une année
entière s'est écoulé mais nous sommes
toujours bloqués aux quatre et la colère
grandit je demande à dieu comment je
suis censé me débarrasser de cette
colère je ne sais pas comment la colère
on nous devient plus forte que notre
tristesse
pendant ce temps les beyrouthins pelt à
reconstruire la zone dévastée
abandonnés par leurs autorités ne
peuvent compter que sur une armée de
volontaires et des ong pour continuer à
déblayer les gravats si aujourd'hui le
quartier reprend vie progressivement les
crises économiques politiques et
sanitaires elle semble être loin d'être
terminée